and they confirmed
oh yeah dude we're we're there now we've
got it surrounded whatever it is
so it wasn't a wasn't a a maybe or a
guest or maybe an airplane
it was some sort of craft that come down
now you know dude was it a satellite
i don't couldn't tell you that um how
[ __ ] crazy does it have to be if you
travel all the way here from another
from another universe and you're god you
got you [ __ ] crash or
well that was unless it's funny you say
that because i was the same way there
was
there was talk of what actually brought
down the roswell
dur that crash and somebody said it was
actually radar
new radar they were using and actually
brought it down
there's some now people today that are
saying that's not true what they did was
they believed that
every part of the world was given a
piece of equipment to see how fast they
could take it apart
and figure out what's making this thing
really work this way
if it's the aliens that are running the
show they'll really find out who the
smart people are
real quick so do you base you figure out
okay
these people are smart these people
aren't smart do we get rid of them now
do we start a pandemic do we kill off
this group right here do we
you know the black plague there were
some discussions with regard to the
black plague
um being a blood type specific
was it blood type specific well that
that was the question
and they said because studies didn't
kill well there was
nobody knew blood types back then okay
they know there was an a b and o and so
they would you know they weren't
transfusing blood i don't even know when
that was
but yeah at what point i'm sure i don't
can't even remember myself what is when
it came back i want to say it was in the
like 1910 1912 and they started to
realize there was some differences in
the blood can you pull up like black
plague wikipedia
yeah that'd be so yeah so yeah well so
they started seeing so how come we
didn't kill everybody
why and he goes the guy that was kind of
came up with if you think a flea
was jumping off rats and giving people
the black plague he goes there was
something else bigger going on and
whether these people weren't
have we figured out all this new you
know this x-type blood these people
aren't very smart let's just eliminate
them and we'll make a disease that's
specific to that
because what's interesting with even
with kovid i've heard people say oh if
you have type a well that was in the
beginning right they were talking about
that type of
certain type of blood types you get
[ __ ] up by it in certain types you're
asymptomatic so it's it's not talking
about that though like in
march of last year right i mean so is it
the people now too that i find
interesting that are getting sick
after they've had their shots they go oh
it's the kovid i'm like well how do you
know it wasn't the shot
let's go back to bope and gara and then
when that thing crashed oh black the
black death
does it say from 1346 it was occurring
in afro eurasia
euro asia from 1934
or from 1346 to 1353
the most fatal pandemic
recorded in human history causing
deaths of 75 to 200 million people
in eurasia and north africa why didn't
it wipe out everybody
that's a lot of [ __ ] people 200
million
i don't even think there's nothing okay
yeah all in like uh
western europe and asia and top in the
top of that north africa
because i'm [ __ ] you weren't really
hungry yeah 1346
to 1353.
so everybody started using seven years
everybody started using ppe back then
and all of a sudden it went away
200 million people but where'd it go how
does it just go away how did it wipe out
everybody because back then you weren't
taking baths you weren't there was no
hygiene i mean how many people could
there have possibly
been in 1343. i certainly didn't think
200
killed 200 million there's what 300
million in the u.s something like that
yeah right now it's exactly i think
we're a little over that but yeah you're
you're damn right
so that that in itself it's a weird
number 200 million seems like everybody
in 1300s would have been dead
so you know again so is that specific
are they trying to wipe certain groups
out
nobody can tell us why though i want to
know why you know again are we just a
bug here that's producing carbon dioxide
for the planet
is there a bigger picture for us i mean
we're so interested in killing each
other and doing harm to each other
and again i don't know if that's part of
the bigger plan um
isn't that crazy though you know carbon
dioxide you know all the carbon dioxide
is supposed to be so bad but it's it's
really giving life
to all the trees and plants and and the
trees
all the vegetation dude the tree is the
most important
element on the planet it absolutely does
everything we need to do you can build
with it
and keep you warm and there's not
another
product on the planet that does that for
you i mean you know other than some
brush and whatnot but if you're if
you're truly looking at trees for what
they are
um if you look at the onslaught of trees
throughout especially through south
america
they're the forest down
so now are these aliens these these
visitors are they watching that
you know is that why brazil all of a
sudden has this onslaught of
of craft you guys whoa now you're
connecting some serious dots here you
see what i'm saying
so you're damaging the planet well we're
not gonna let you damage the planet the
same thing with
um you know when we talked about um uh
rio de janeiro in brazil um and that
that incident that took place with ufo
crashed here
yeah so we talked about in the last
podcast you came in on yeah and um
they found more and more information out
now there's more information on youtube
that's about about it
they were able to move the vehicle
though after it crashed there's nothing
there now but there was definitely
something that crashed there
um brazil has a long long history with
ufos and extraterrestrials yeah
i've seen a lot of things on tv and a
lot of things on the internet about
about ufos and and like aliens and stuff
in brazil
which is crazy because you know today
you don't i don't think about them being
there but you know when you talk to they
would go over they would interview some
of these people and talk about their
experiences
um you know it's one thing to to sit
there
and make up a story it's another thing
that while you're telling a story to be
absolutely terrified out of your mind
and i
in my eyes looking at some of the folks
that are telling the stories
it just doesn't seem it doesn't seem
like they're lying it doesn't seem like
it's a fake story
and then like i say when you take into
consideration uh
different politicians that are getting
involved now
for me again was more interesting i told
you when we went through this thing to
figure out what had crashed in brazil
i've got some friends of mine here that
are former
police officers from there who deal with
a group called bop oh yeah
and they're the guys that actually
confirmed it for us so it wasn't of you
know sort of hey we think we've got
something crashed here they confirmed it
hey now we got a crashed vehicle here
dude
and it's not from any place we know and
oh by the way america's here also
helping us out so and this who was the
dude from
bop who you talked to um this is a group
here in florida
i'm a little adamant to even bring the
guy's name up um one one of the guys was
one of my little cia buddies i was
telling you about earlier okay
um they came they moved here to this
country about
five years ago after they retired and
the reason they did that
from brazil from brazil okay um i mean
i think the last before they moved here
one of the guys had killed 11 people in
his neighborhood
jesus so when they came here we do a
thing every year called sniper craft
here and they came down and would
participate they always took first place
they were guys were very accomplished
shooters across the board
sniper competitions it was a sniper
competition called sniper craft here in
in
central florida and they would come down
every year for that so i got to know
these guys
really really well these aren't these
aren't ufo guys these aren't these are
all
kind of meteor knuckle draggers knuckle
dragger meat heads
yeah dude they're i mean they're special
operations yeah completely um
matter of fact they initially when they
won here
they won the event um the state
department because he had killed 11
people
wanted more information on him thinking
maybe he's a terrorist or coming from
some sort of other background other than
a law enforcement background
how does he what is he like what does he
tell everybody he killed 11 people or is
that like a is that like a
like a no i mean it's just a reality of
what it is
um his wife when i went over there his
wife was actually wearing a gun and she
was vacuuming the house and i kind of
made a joke like
hey what's that all about and she goes
uh how do you get away with killing 11
people by the way
well i mean he's the first of all he's a
police officer okay
so there are no civil rights in brazil
right so they give you an order if you
don't pay attention
instantly so he's a police officer
brazil so every
person he killed was documented somehow
oh yeah
it's not just him being like yo bro no
no no no no it's it's
it's it's in the middle of his job yeah
what's going on yeah yeah absolutely
he's not like i say just out killing
people he's not just bragging about it
bingo
bingo and these are these are numbers
that are necessary for us to know
because when he comes into the u.s the
state department wants to know who are
you
okay why are you here because i can
promise you if the state department gets
in touch with brazil
and the authorities there and they said
hey we'd like to look at his record and
they went back and said hey
you killed 31 people in the last six
years why didn't you tell us that
so he just comes here and immediately
volunteers that information because
they're going to find that out and
they're gonna start asking questions as
to why you didn't so to get a green card
here was tough for these guys
because of that they did extensive
background on on there's six of them
that came here
they were afraid they were gonna get
killed in brazil if they stayed there
that's how bad it is
um just because of all of the trouble i
mean it's not
it's not your normal white collar type
you know
uh gangs that are marauding around
he always had to worry about his wife
getting killed being a cop in brazil is
very correct
and and these guys just aren't cops the
name of the group they're with is called
gara
they're actually a real high-end swat
guys bope are above them they're more
like special operations guys
okay so they they are not liked
they um when gara shows up bad things
are about to go left real quick okay
so when i started when i called those
guys
because when i first heard this rumor
that this crash had happened in rio de
janeiro
i called one of my guys that was a
retired captain out there
he didn't even know about it he's like
nah i don't know what dude what
what are you talking about i said
nothing nothing
so when i called the other guys and they
actually called bob and i was told the
bope was the one that was actually the
perimeter secure making sure that nobody
else was allowed to get near it and they
confirmed it oh yeah dude
we're we're there now we've got it
surrounded whatever it is
what's up world you just watched a clip
from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly
pure uncut content straight from the
jungles of columbia if you want to watch
the full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace
foreign